leonard lopate is with us I've had the
pleasure of working with him many times
the Brooklyn Academy of Music he'll be
moderating our session today which is
entitled a matter for us post-colonial
nations and color lines Leonard is the
host of new york and company on WNYC as
many of you know and we're very
privileged to have him here as well as
he is partners today in our first panel
for the midnight Ranger humanities
festival thank you very much and over to
you Leonard Thank You Jamie I read
recently that poor people in Tanzania
and Namibia have been applying something
called caroga to their skin it's a
homemade mixture of lye and bleach that
gives them what they call the Michael
Jackson look there's hardly a place on
earth where social and political
hierarchies linked to skin colored don't
exist but this development does come as
something of a surprise as wev Dubois
and others have pointed out the notion
of whiteness is largely a modern
invention and its genesis according to
most academics is the transatlantic
slave trade and the colonialism that
emerged with it but is that completely
true we're talking today inspired by
salman rushdie's midnight's children
hasn't skin shade been a component of
the caste system on the Indian
subcontinent and what was the effect of
the British Raj on that what roles to
class gender and migration play in
post-colonial tensions those are some of
the things we'll be talking about today
and this panel is perfect for that a
Manning Marable director of both the
African American Studies program and the
center for contemporary American history
at Columbia University patricia j
williams professor of law at columbia
university also writes a bi-monthly
column for the nation called diary of a
Mad Professor I hope you're not going to
be too
and Gary visvanathan is a class of 1933
professor in the humanities and director
of the southern Asian Institute at
Columbia University that doesn't mean
she's in the class of 1933 I'm pleased
that you all either that or you've aged
incredibly well because we have two
african-american panelists here I guess
I should begin by asking you whether we
should consider American racial politics
as a let as a legacy of colonialism
visits an American thing or is to do we
see this is all part of the same
colonial past Manning well in the United
States racism is word Americans believe
they know a lot about but what is
curious and perhaps this is a good point
of departure is that the Americans are
largely distinct and outside of a
general global discussion about the
meaning of race particularly in
contemporary life the United States has
a fairly backward notion of what race is
that most Americans believe that race is
something that is either biologically or
genetically anchored or derived that it
is relatively fixed but most people
throughout the world have a very
different point of view about the nature
of race that it's dynamic that it is
that it is not a thing but a process a
process that is the product of
structures of power and inequality one
way of thinking about racism and this is
an oversimplification but the way that I
relate it to my undergraduate students
here at Columbia is that racism is the
three P's prejudice power and privilege
prejudice the stereotyping of
individuals
groups based on their phenotype of their
physical features of some ritual or have
it or for some manifestation of their
activity of that they do the use of
power to carry out the stereo to
reinforce domination of and then
privilege structures that benefit those
in power over and above those who are
subordinated and if one looks throughout
the world you find that when racism is
defined simply as intolerance or when
racism is defined as we do in the United
States is simply a fact of biological
life between one group and another and
it's taken completely outside of a
discussion about power and resources
then in the United States we think about
race is something that's fixed and we
can't change Pat would you agree with
Manning on that do you think that our
situation is different from what we
might find in other places where there
was slavery like the Caribbean or Brazil
I think that it's it's the same end
different in the
and in that I think that where racism
and race are involved populations are
generally unconscious of its power that
is its power the unconsciousness of the
given population so in that sense I
don't think the United States is
particularly different I it is the
direct analogy to colonialism I think we
have an internal sense of migration an
internal sense of rather than an
external power our sense of the
colonizing around race has occurred
within the nation and I think that's one
the difference between for example
cornish Empire going out and colonizing
India for example then finally I guess I
would agree with many marble to the
extent we are unconscious of it were
much more unconscious of it than they
used to be perhaps when it was
explicitly written into law and if you
look back 100 years the definition of
race was one that was quite malleable it
included Association you were black if
you associated and you could be
litigated d found to be a black person
even if we're not supposedly genetic or
picture direct ancestors didn't come
from Africa it had to do with how you
dressed had to do with how you behaved
whom you it was it had many aspects of
what we call class as well as a
biological phenomenon as well as fina
world
talk about classes as well professor is
one of them are people judged by the
darkness of their skin in India if
you're speaking about now you know I
think that question is really vary
depending on exactly where you're
located geographically as well as within
the caste hierarchy and also within a
religious hierarchy if you're speaking
if you're asking this question across
time and our people judged according to
the on the basis of their skin and you
want to factor in the history of
colonialism surely I think you know what
you might see is the consolidation of
the Indian peoples coming under once one
color even though of course there may be
a range of actual physical colors and
this is actually one of the things that
i have found interesting about colonial
history the extent to which you know
color itself is sort of reduced to some
abstract entity and that racial
antipathy on basis of color is often a
kind of constructed racial identity so
this is how I think one might think of
the colonial impact but if we go back
before the colonial era in fact three
millennia to the invasion of the
indo-europeans wasn't word distinctions
made they were light-skinned they were
the same people that conquered much of
Europe and as I understood it part of
the the development of the caste system
had to do with darkness and the people
in the South discriminated against
because they are darker than than a
Brahmin even today well sure I mean this
is the dr ian myth which has been
floated around for quite some time and
there's been a lot of disputation of
that myth and particularly from you know
from south India and the resistant
movements that are that are located
within the group that I think in the
West is known as Untouchables they have
really made a significant impact on the
power of the re and myth you know the
darkest kinder thing well this is this
is I think the real question the the the
writings the political writings and
literary writings of the untouchable
groups those writings have been fact
disputed whether the so-called arion
invaders were these white skinned people
and they've drawn from the evidence of
documents to suggest that you know this
color issue is actually a fabricated
issue and it has been used as weapon to
subjugate dravidian people's well one of
the ways of the untouchables have tried
to get out of this whole thing was to
convert to Christianity and of course
the story of American slaves involves
mass conversion as well perhaps
different strategies but perhaps you can
tell us a bit about the untouchables and
then we can get into why Christianity
was so appealing to slaves The
Untouchables feel that by becoming
Christians they get they take themselves
out of the caste system do they really
yeah I think this is a very interesting
question because they're the expectation
of course is that the movement out of
unimpressed religion like Hinduism for
untouchables and into Christianity would
elevate Untouchables into you know into
a sort of an era of freedom but yet what
I would is actually quite striking about
Christian converts
what's the untouchables is the you know
degree to which hierarchy is preserved
within the Christian communities for
instance even in the structure of
churches Untouchables who were conversed
Christianity were often given a
different place to sit in the church
burial grounds were different they did
not have the right to be to be buried in
the same burial ground as people who
were called the native the not native
but the European Christians so there was
a caste system even in amongst the
Christian converts and I think it's very
telling as to how Christianity absorbed
some of the aspects of racialism that it
purported to transcend for the slaves
the American slaves there were different
times there was integration initially
with conversion and then segregation
later would do you think that
integration the fact that people sat
next to each other in the churches in
the earliest days your furring Arad
that's it that's what I remember the
first day it's the first wave and no
second it's a little more complicated
than that oh so it was no comment I want
to back up a little bit just for about
30 seconds o people of African descent
who arrived in the Americas came from
innumerable of types of states of
non-state societies and very rigid and
very complex societies they spoke
different languages had different
ethnicities some of Muslims some were
Muslims and so consequently as people of
African descent came to what became the
United States they had to construct for
themselves a new kind of culture a new
sense of collective identity and during
the 18th in the early 19th century the
church the Christian of faith helped to
create a kind of scaffolding for the
construction of a national identity for
African Americans so the relationship
between people of African descent in the
US and how they
viewed Christianity because they made
Christianity their own in terms of the
construction of a new discourse language
the whole relationship between is Dubois
put it in the souls of black folk the
essence of black faith is the preacher
the music and the frenzy the
construction of rituals and symbols that
gave people not just the sense of hope
and a sense of historic possibility so
that makes it in many real ways somewhat
different from what we're seeing in the
rest of the colonized world but there
are also parallels as well because
people in South India people in Africa
the Caribbean and the United States
using this very imperfect and
contradictory tool of faith and these
institutions fashion liberation
strategies to resist oppression and even
though they were also fraught with
contradictions as you just described
they were also in many real ways
emancipatory please please don't wait
for me to ask you to speak it's your all
people have strong ideas just jump in
when you feel like it was actually a
parallel situation in India tube
precisely as a response to the racialism
of what was considered as white
Christianity that in fact there were
amongst Christian converts one could see
an attempt to forge an indigenous
Christianity and in fact the references
to Jesus as an oriental rather than
Jesus as a European and this is very
much part of that and to recover the
circle so called oriental roots of
Christianity and to found a new church
as it were that would be truly resistant
truly Liberatore but truly also detached
from the attached the the associations
that Christianity has had
with European colonialism so and this
played a very important part in national
national liberation movements and Indian
Christians for a long time have
expressed deep regret and that you know
that the Christian Indian Christians are
construed not to be neutral Indians and
they often point precisely this aspect
of their religious history I as another
parallel my page is Latin America where
I think the whole question of liberation
theology is is is one of using the
scaffolding of Christianity create one
which was indigenous and in some ways
the American black church is closer to
the American southern white church than
many other areas where the actual
colonists was in Europe or at a greater
distance as we've been seeing in Africa
with some even where certain brands of
Catholicism would not really be
recognized by the Vatican they're just
simply tolerated by the bed and I think
that that first wave of what has
happened to the Catholic Church is why
you know Christian evangelicals and
fundamentals have had such hard work to
go into Latin American reconstructive
with the Assemblies of God and so forth
and the kind of missionary work that is
going on
in Latin America from more conservative
you know sort of recoup from Catholic
liberation theology has been a very
interesting political phenomenon
precisely at least in some of the kind
of preaching because it departs so from
the more colonizing influences of
traditional Christianity Manning talked
about the development of a collective
identity how much of a role does skin
shade and I'm talking about the wide
range of skin shade clay in one sense of
cultural and collective identity I think
it's absolutely critical in a racialized
society where there's a color-coded
hierarchy on identity is always
constructed from within and imposed from
without that is our identity is
fashioned by how we imagine ourselves
and the significant others in our lives
our parents are lovers or friends family
but it is also the identity that's
imposed on you by the larger world so we
have a situation where we have may have
a collective identity but we also have a
wide range of authenticity and not an in
authenticity absolutely so for example
in New York City well I'll use myself as
a good example oh I'm an
african-american if you ask most
Americans who see me coming walking down
the street all what's the first thing
you identify about that person most
Americans and this is not to say
Americans or racist but most Americans
probably would say he's black even
though the he prefigures black and that
is a gendered identity he they would
probably the black trunks the he okay
the black Trump's the she same person
goes to South Africa
town if I don't open my mouth so you
can't tell where I'm from and I would
probably have to change my glasses
although nowadays perhaps not all in
south africa i would be colored in
brazil all depending upon my suit and
the context i could possibly beat bracha
white the Brazilian has used the
expression money lightens the skin so
that in South Africa for example under
the apartheid regime Japanese were
considered colored oh sorry white and
Chinese considered colored so that this
is what i mean by racism or structures
of hierarchy are impacted by of notions
of prejudice power and privilege the
Japanese have symbolically more power
economically and politically than the
Chinese did to the old to the the old
regime of apartheid South Africa hence
the Japanese magically become white all
symbolically a person who looks like me
in Brazil functions like a white person
it's an interest in fact if I can if you
give me 30 seconds there's a story that
just occurred to me that actually makes
this point best 20 years ago I was a
fellow at the Aspen Institute and um
there a series of seminars in the summer
one of the members of the seminar with
me was general ed brownie was the third
star three star general who at the time
was about to become Reagan's chief arms
negotiator in Switzerland with the
Soviet Union he and I took a bus
together to go to the seminar every day
and he and I got into a conversation in
the little mini bus about the Soviet
Union and the con the global conflict
between capitalism and communism and I
asked him isn't there any possibility
for us to come to terms with the Soviet
Union and he said you don't understand
Manning the Russians aren't like us they
lack Western civilization they never had
the Renaissance they never understood
real human feelings and I said aren't
you saying that their political ideology
of communism makes them intolerant he
said communism has nothing to do with it
the reason we can never trust the
Russians is because he thought a minute
he said because they are asiatics now
here's the question if for Rowney the it
was worse to be quote unquote Asiatic
than it was to be communist and to be
communist an Asiatic meant that there
could be no real negotiation but the
question is now that the Russians are no
longer communist have they become white
at least in South Africa they are well
so we're talking about other nas's well
that's right way and that leads to the
thought if everyone were the same color
would we still have to find other ways
to identify the other like in this case
asiatics or people who who just haven't
had Western civilization right now we
have a president who seems to think the
new white man's burden is to bring
democracy to to the Middle East or as
Maureen Dowd said today to give them
trickle-down democracy that was
collaborative formulation but is since
we so often think about in terms of
color and light that old blue song if
you like well it's all right if you're
Brown stick around but if you're black
get back could we say that if we didn't
have that we would have to have
something else I'm ask you a lawyer and
well I I wasn't gonna answer as a lawyer
let me just I've been certainly
throughout history there's always been
some form of other ring and but what
strikes me is particularly precarious
with regard to color at this moment in
history is that we've become a knot of
society not a culture but a world very
dependent upon visual media and as the
war on terrorism has has has gathered
steam so much of that has been
crystallized in new suspect profiling
which seems to have been borrowed
wholesale from police work in the United
States or elsewhere and the new science
of population control seems grounded in
the practices of control of populations
of color given as well again the the
general popular media which featured the
good guys as wearing not just white hats
but white skins I think this is
enormously powerful and so I think for
the time being what we're dealing with
is seeing increasing numbers of people
being divided into light skinned and
dark skinned around the world even wear
those
ethnic and religious complications are
in fact more nuanced as basis basis for
in enmity well in the Bollywood films
Gary aren't even now aren't most of the
heroes and heroines light skinned
especially the women yeah yeah that's
true they are but yet at the same time
there are an increasing number of
Bollywood heroines who do come from
south India and one of the things of
course that's people dover is the fact
that you know that that identification
between south and darkness is erased by
the time they get to Bollywood and then
there is a different mix that takes
place all together and of course it's
true that there is this kind of angst
about skin color but if i can just
backtrack a little bit because you know
listening to Manning's anecdote i was
struck by this really in a wonderful
passage in Midnight's Children since
that sort of the impetus for these
discussions where the protagonist father
talks about becoming white you know that
he that gradually he he's transformed
into whiteness and he even remarks on
how you know secretly he's he believes
that virtual resides in whiteness though
nobody will ever acknowledge it and I
think an even more significant part in
that passage or in that section is where
while the protagonist father is
undergoing this transformation and
whiteness the major industrialists in
India are also undergoing this
transformation into whiteness and I
think the point that Manning had made
about how economic power is allied to
whiteness is really dramatized in
Rushdie's own novel and that in fact I
think he tries to get at that
identification between a few know the
the rise in economic power of a circle
class in India and their assumption of a
place that had been vacated by the
British but for the both the British and
many of the people who've come out of
the colonial experience didn't it come
down to the best dark-skinned people can
hope for
to be almost the same but not quite
almost the same but not white yeah
that's part of that filtration theory
which is now being translated by Bush
into these other places of the world yes
this notion that you know the filtering
Western values to another society will
produce an intermediate class that will
be familiar with your norms your values
your language your ethics and so forth
and will act as a go-between between the
you know between the Western elite and
the you know the lower orders but
precisely because they're into this is
an intermediate class they will be not
white not quite but the British are very
proud of the fact that Michael and da
che arundhati roy and salman rushdie on
Booker Prize winners it's almost a way
of proving that they've gotten past that
although if you travel around England
you know that they haven't gotten past
it at all I mean I I don't quite know
how to respond to that that sense of
celebration I actually think that it may
have more to do with reasserting the
idea of the Commonwealth rather than
paying any real tribute to writers of
the formerly colonized a couple of years
ago they celebrated the all of the the
boats that came from the Caribbean
bringing people after the war to fill
the spots that were empty because so
many soldiers had died and I know
something like Carol Phillips who
teaches at bar nerd here his family was
one of those so they they they trot the
the people who have succeeded because of
that migration out yet if you speak to
any of them like cast Phillips they live
Tara but they live lives of terrible
discrimination until they were able to
get past
I think that there's also a dimension
which color has become a kind of verbal
weapon so it's not just visual I said it
was visual largely but I think it's also
as it's kind of a metaphor and the best
illustration of that was how clinton
became black as Chris Rock made the
famous joke about it but again to go
back 100 years in he would he might have
been litigated his bike because of whom
the people with whom he hung out Vernon
Jordan that would have made him in a
court of law actually black in some
jurisdictions it was how he behaved made
like less than a Southern gentleman he
would have been litigated as a black
person it didn t davies he is live less
behave less and the southern gentleman
he behaved just like a southern jam so
it is it just it also this intermediate
class is those who patrol the border who
are a sort of you know can go either way
was also tified perhaps by Lonnie Quinn
ear you know we at the same time there
were many people rejoicing oh well we
have a new interracial class of people
in the United States who have one black
parent and one white parent and and and
the demographics are going to change in
this regard well Lani Guinier could have
been analyzed as the perfect example of
that she has a white mother a Jewish
mother and a black father during the
time that she was being attacked she was
the loonie black lady that's how she was
reduced and so the the question of how
you can go either way does is this an
ideological one not just a visual one
it's metaphoric in terms of this it's
the connotation of what being black
means in fact the whole Democratic Party
has been
racialized colored in a way mmm I wanted
to add something Pat said something
about all boundaries that I want to kind
of build on what what racialization is
about really has always been about in
its essence whether it's in South Asia
under the British colonialism or in the
American South during Jim Crow or part
aid is the construction of boundaries
between individuals and between
societies at first in the United States
when slavery was constructed and the
genocide wars against Native Americans
occurred the boundaries were the
boundaries between the European
settlements on the coast and the
frontier or they were also the
boundaries between the Masters mansions
in the sleigh of shanties those same
kinds of boundaries exist in a
racialized society today so that
racialized people carry our boundaries
that is the boundary of our skin around
with us wherever we go so that there is
a a rough separation that symbolically
is represented by color but it's actual
content is not that that is it is the
distance between having resources having
education having power and not having
any of those things and so and we use
color as a way of coding the absence or
the realization of those structures of
power so the challenge has always been
for racialized people how do we erase
the boundaries that separate us from the
access to resources and power while not
obliterating those boundaries that
helped helped informed who we are that
is our identity because identity in so
many real ways is not just what people
have imposed on you but also how by
fighting back against what's imposed on
you you begin to create something
who your own voice and so there is this
tremendous tension between in the United
States and being black all all you know
over the last 400 years this is a
recurring problem that is that the
racism drives you crazy and yet at the
same time the fight against it gives
sustains hope dignity it gives you a
sense of direction and purpose it gives
you a sense of history and agency and in
you know for african-americans we're
dedicated to understand and destroy the
we have to understand the very thing
that we're dedicated to destroy which is
race and yet as we do that what happens
to our identity well since race is a
construct an unscientific construct than
that identity is something that is
separate and that's the subject of a
film in Australian film I don't know if
you've seen rapid proof fence we're good
well intentioned but obviously mistaken
Australians believe that mixed-race
Aborigines if they are allowed to
integrate into the white world and then
intermarry with white people eventually
will become totally civilized and nobody
will even notice or know that they were
once Aborigines which brings me back to
Salman Rushdie the number of the
midnight children have light hair and
blue eyes they're mixed-race children
they are the bastard children of
colonialism they also would they also
eventually be expected to be to rise
above or would they always be considered
something lesser because of the colonial
connection i think krista uses the you
know the idea of these mixed children
I'm very effective in very productive
ways because I think he tries to tap
that theme into you know the the issue
of India's modernization and looking at
this at this mixed breed not as a as a
corruption or as an aspect of India's
past that has to be rejected but in fact
to use these very children who have
these these thin this mixed blood as
perhaps the India's future as well so
there is a large extent I think he
intends his readers are maybe you know
the degree of success may vary as to who
the reader is but certainly I think he
does intend for us to look at the these
children as a product of you know a sort
of an inescapable a cross between India
and England and to look at that cross as
the basis for for a modernization that
would that could that could absorb the
past without quite rejecting it all
together I do remember is such a great
film where the this woman who was half
and half was really never really
accepted even though she spoke I guess
in that case it was being Bali as well
as everyone else you grown up in India
but everybody called her the Anglo
or something along those lines so is
that changing and in time do you think
these things do change well today's
India i think it's just so hard to avoid
the sort of in-your-face quality of the
change because it is really hard now to
locate the boundaries you know of what
what is Western what is you know I hate
to use words like indigenous or nature
but it I I hope the audience will
understand what I'm referring to and of
course you know movements of your
political movements that are deeply
alarmed by what they see as the
corruption of a pure indian selfhood you
know it's it's those movements that are
producing some of the more alarming
tendencies you know sort of fascist and
Hindu leading tendencies which still
harken back to some kind of you know
territorial purity and using that notion
to to exclude to marginalize and in fact
I think instituting a new not a color
hierarchy as such but you know a new a
new hierarchy based on location in the
land who was there first becomes the
question of priority not what colored
skin oh you have but what which is
preferable being a cultural nationalist
and saying that you don't want to accept
the the things that have been imposed on
you or excelling at cricket and soccer
as has happened in some of the former
British colonies to the point where it
didn't India just beat Britain to the
great joy of the whole whole Indian
nation but but in a way that looks like
it is and justice eating to the the
things that were imposed by the colonial
power you're shaking your head no Manik
no BMO's fall everywhere America will
wind up being in the know Mike's
imperialist
no I'm channeling for CLR James here in
nello CLR James in beyond a boundary in
his classic work shows how cricket is
this is in fact the analogy is quite a
nice one with African American
spirituality and faith that the West
Indian people took cricket and made it
their own and how they articulate their
nationalism their culture their
physicality their sense of time and
music and their gift of grace all of
that is found in cricket and colonized
people seized it and turned it around
James names Naismith created basketball
in at though at the YMCA in springfield
missouri in 1892 i think things have
changed since then one of the reasons i
loved Midnight's Children is this dreamy
quality and it does feel like a lot of
what happens with this taking and making
of one's own is that you sort of dream
through the imagery and mythology even
of the oppressor and it becomes your own
and to some extent you can end up on the
one hand like Michael Jackson where the
Dreaming becomes so literal that you
carve it upon your body or on the other
hand you know or somewhere but i was
thinking of the second thing of six
degrees of separation John where's six
degrees of separation or Pudd'nhead
Wilson the sense of tourney oneself
inside out or changing places and I
guess the few years ago there was a play
of a presentation of Pudd'nhead Wilson
in which all the parts got mixed up so
that the light skinned child who was
adopted by the
or placed in the white family was
actually played by a very dark-skinned
actor and delivering all these same
lines and it did sound a little bit like
Michael Jackson smoking and this it
became quite surreal watching this
without any sense of visual racial
boundary but you began to hear the
politics of it being spoken you began to
hear what you know somebody called the
Uncle Tom voice writ large Anna deavere
Smith the performance artist does a lot
of this mushy she's done her twilight
Los Angeles and yeah by mixing up the
voices are actually of for example of a
white police chief of Los Angeles but
you'll have a 12 year old latino boys
speaking the his actual words and it's a
very fascinating kind of again sort of
magical realist Midnight's Children
begins with the partition of India and
Pakistan and what follow is one of the
saddest and bloodiest mass migrations in
world history of course
african-americans were also forced into
a great and awful migration and I'm
thinking wondering about the impact of
migration doesn't migration mean one has
to relinquish the past in order to
survive in the present and what is that
what has that meant for the the the
countries that rusty has written about
what has that meant do you think for the
adjustment of African Americans to this
country well I think rusty couldn't have
written this normal if he had sort of
relinquish the past as a memory as a
memory and as a concept in fact but he
didn't but well he has relinquished the
pass another way because he lives
elsewhere but people were forced to give
up everything that they had to move to
another place because of some artificial
decision yeah but I'm not sure whether I
would agree with you that you know by
moving someplace else you relinquish the
power
Aston I think that that that that gives
a very partial view of migration as a
sort of very finite and very linear and
that gives you somehow don't you know
continue aspects of yourself simply sell
some place else in fact I think that is
one of the remarkable things about the
the writings of people who have migrated
the the fact that they reveal the extent
to which there they are met their
identities their existence someplace
else it that they are living such
layered existences so to that extent I
actually I would disagree with you I'm
just talking about an idea actually that
one would actually leave something
behind and I think in a way that it was
rush these particular case in a few if
one wants to say well he left India and
Pakistan and and migrated to England and
made that his home and then subsequently
the United States then what is where
does where do India and Pakistan figure
in in his consciousness are they merely
sort of the sort of productive sites for
his own writing experimentation or do
they have no other role I think that in
some ways the writing does became it
does become a natural outcome of having
to work through the reality of migration
it's certainly not the kind of migration
we're talking about in fact no to even
speak about migration in relationship to
the african-american experiences is
really to do grave injustice right or to
the transatlantic slave exactly so I
think that they did the issue of
language is really critical and and I
actually feel that we are sort of
hampered by the inadequacy of our
vocabularies to talk about movements of
people from one region to another right
the transatlantic slave trade took place
over about four centuries in it involved
perhaps as many as a hundred million
people it in the night in the Americas
and the Caribbean about 15 million
people were transported for
about fifteen fifty two about eighteen
seventy but it doesn't include the
millions of people whose bodies were
thrown overboard in the South Atlantic
or the millions who died in the barrack
uns of the fort's awaiting
transportation or the millions who were
killed in Africa during the wars that
were provoked by Europeans with the
influx of textiles and weapon weaponry
over a period of several centuries so
yeah there there are differences but the
parallels though with India um in terms
of migrations the first thing I thought
of was the great migration of nineteen
fifteen nineteen sixty we're about six
million six and a half million
african-americans moved from the rural
South to the urban north in uh what was
in the United States of the one of the
most profound mass migrations of
Americans in the first half of the two
of the 20th century african-americans
went from being ninety percent rural and
ninety percent southern in 1902 being
now the most urban population on the
North American continent so that if the
analogies historical analogies are rough
and they're inherently dangerous to make
but there is something of the fact that
the the forced migration of populations
in Pakistan and India created a kind of
mass trauma or a distancing in a way of
one kind of history to the entering of a
new kind of history the same parallels
do fit for black America because in our
memory of black culture and
consciousness so much of the blues could
not have been constructed originally on
in as much as people love blues in this
city new york city had to come from the
Mississippi Delta the products of our
culture and our faith and rituals coming
out of the deep south in a rural area
are a product of a
historical moment and with the trauma of
MU of movement of the migration a whole
new way of seeing ourselves and
imagining our communities comes into
being and I think that perhaps the the
the analogy doesn't quite fit with India
and Pakistan but in but in a real sense
Rushdie points to the construction of
new kinds of societies where people see
themselves in different ways and that
the migration was a kind of break kind
of a transition in a way I think that I
remember having a conversation with
Helen bambor who's a doctor in Britain
who works with refugee populations and
she described the fact that they
frequently will hold themselves together
through tremendously traumatic
experiences of war and dispossession and
they come to Britain as asylum seekers
and they confront racism and Britain and
that's where they snap that's where
their mental state is most endangered
and we're having this conversation in
the context of precisely the American
migration of blacks from north to south
the bulk of that migration particularly
occurring just around the time of the
civil rights movement coming two great
cities finding and finding police
officers and other causing constraints
and job constraints the economy sort of
fell through in places like Chicago
that's when the riots occurred that's
when people really had difficulty with
what they had idealized as the freedom
of the north the migration north and and
and it's also interesting I think that's
the point at which you see in even an
african-american literature a certain
film a certain kind of magical realism
that thinking particularly of movies
like Charles Burnett's to sleep with
anger in which uses the language of
migration you know it's there's sweet
home down-home you come to the to the
new world and the trickster figure
follows you somehow as a kind of
nostalgic memory and bedevils your every
effort to assimilate essentially we have
with rusty as a man who
living in in other countries writing
passionately about his his the India and
Pakistan and we saw the same thing in
with the black migr writers went to
France mostly Richard Wright just ions
and especially James Baldwin writing
passionately about America at the same
times at same time they felt they
couldn't live here I don't know if
there's any if we see any parallels
there but perhaps sometimes people have
to leave to be able to really understand
what's going on that's right well it's
it's not surprising many writers here
who live in the city have to get out of
the city in order to be able to write
about it that you need some distance
from the thing that you love or the
thing that drives you crazy and for
Jimmy I know that Jimmy's deep Jimmy
Baldwin's deep love for this country not
so much what it was but what it could be
richards right Richard Wright's passion
for the United States and the
possibility of what a truly multiracial
democracy might look like could not be
realized in his own time and so he could
only express that love through anger and
protest at a great distance but the
distance gave him the space to
articulate this alternative vision and
looking at South Asian writers um you
know a lot large numbers of them who
have in fact moved to the west Viet
England or the United States or Canada
but what is quite striking of course is
that in their writings they're not
necessarily focused on the place that
they live immediately but do right so
obsessively one might say with you know
the countries that they've left behind
India Pakistan Sri Lanka Bangladesh etc
and in reality if one looks at the
engagement with happenings in in the
countries that they've left behind you
know issues of the environment for
instance or religious fundamentalism or
political corruption I'm very struck by
how in these writers you know certainly
did there must be an element of guilt I
think everybody has that sense of of no
longer being involved you know with the
movements going on in one's own country
but the engagement from elsewhere of
course it'll it allows for a certain
distance and a capacity to write more
dispassionately about these developments
but I also think it gives the space for
talking about the future of their
countries and more utopian ways that
might be a little more difficult if one
were actively involved with one's own
environmental I certainly feel that
every time I go to India and I do spend
a lot of time there I feel enormously
depressed in a way that I don't when I'm
out here because I feel that there's
some capacity for moving towards another
stage of activity whereas when I when I
am in India I feel so engulfed by sort
of the despair of things that I do often
wonder whether writing from the outside
gives scope for certain can you tow p
envision that might be not necessarily
available with one with one we're
writing
from within the situation and both
utopian and fundamentalist it's even
when you were speaking i was thinking of
Zadie Smith's white teeth that the
distance is both the the fertile ground
for / kind of utopianism but also a kind
of nostalgia that hardens into a kind of
fundamentalism another factor might be
the circumstances why you left whether
you left because you were unhappy with
where you were or whether you were
forcing Jose donoso probably as much as
anybody responsible for magical realism
died recently he told me that when he
was forced to leave chile because of the
finish a government he was in madrid
sunday santiago became the most
wonderful city in the world and he wrote
about it as a lost paradise and then
after finish a fell and he went back he
said he found it was his depressing jerk
water a place that was nothing like what
he had made it into so there's if you li
if you're forced to leave you may very
well remember things quite differently
than as in your case you keep on going
back and almost reinforcing some of the
worst depressions of the there are some
of the reasons that you might that might
have made it easier for you to leave in
the first place yeah i guess that's true
do at the same time I I do think it's
very hard for a lot of people who've
left to sort of find an adequate role in
you know for themselves in their
countries without quite seeming as as
but not quite sure how to phrase this
that you know what I think one is always
afraid of sort of coming in at it from
from a perspective that doesn't quite
share the immediate you know travails of
the situation I've often heard that you
know if one had to deal with this 365
days of the year you know it would be
you it would be a different kind of
response and if one experiences this for
say 60 days in you or 95 days of you
does it matter how one looks at it I
Salman Rushdie once wrote the novel is
the novel is the stage upon which the
great debates of society can be
conducted he says not only are they
meant to entertain or to amuse but to
provoke and to question as he puts it
everything in every possible way now he
sees it as the role of the novel is it
can the novel do things that someone
who's doing serious sociological
analysis or political analysis can't do
I know I think from no one has to think
one has to acknowledge sort of the
writers investment in his or her own
mission and seeing that as having you
know direct socio-political impact
though but first you know I think by and
large no it's it's not it's not all that
easy to accept that you know writing a
great novel of that would lead towards
some social transformation would
necessarily produce that transformation
I'm not saying anything that's
particularly inspiring here but there it
does reveal I think a big gap between
the headiness of the artistic mission
and the the day-to-day realities that do
involve two active but also very mundane
activities on the ground which don't
really get into you know sort of the the
more elevated reaches of academia or you
don't art you don't write novels Manning
well I think that you know I'm not
literature is not my thing I'm a mundane
social scientist
but what I've learned from the people I
admire in literature is that great
literature changes the way we see
ourselves and that's the key in terms of
literature and its power it's because
it's the power of imagination and it can
place us it can catapult us in the sense
of I think of Richard Wright's black boy
right creates a world of 1925
Mississippi Greenwood Mississippi that
no longer exists but through the book we
enter that world through rushdie's
midnight's children we enter that world
we understand the world from that point
of view and it helps us to see ourselves
in a different way and I'm currently
working on this biography of Malcolm X
and I think the parallel for me is that
Malcolm's great strength was that he
changed the way black people saw
themselves and in that sense his
function was very much like that of a
novel I wouldn't remove the role of
literature so far from social scientists
and then as a lawyer I think that the
same kinds of interpretive dilemmas that
theorists in literature for example are
facing or what we are facing in in terms
of the interpretation of the
Constitution one of the reasons I so
does agree with Scalia and Thomas are
that they are strict textualist they
have a sad kind of nostalgia for the
founding fathers in the way they thought
this very little play between the word
and its meaning you know and it bent
this it meant that in 17 whatever or 18
so and so and that's all it can mean and
people who interpret that closely with
no sense of play not only have no
literary sense
there you know I I feel it risks a kind
of punitive pneus a kind of it's a
constructed nostalgia that's what I
meant by fundamentalism earlier it's a
kind of nostalgia for a world that that
that once existed but the fundamentalist
really hasn't experienced but knows it
must be better because again in the
context of for example Zadie Smith's
you've encountered racism rather than an
ideal world in the New Britain as a poet
the hope of a movement in the civil
rights movement when you came North has
been dashed and therefore you idealize
and imagine and make it or even you know
we still you know imagine the city on
the hill and and that's why people come
fundamentalists around the Constitution
or whatever bought textual body that's
that's a study of words the study of
relationships that that I think is
central to the psychology of literary
interpretation in a few moments I'm
going to open this up to questions from
you but Gary you told me that the music
of southern India has become popular
throughout the country even though
southern Indians have been relatively
discriminated against is that is there
any similarity to the popularity of
hip-hop music in this country with young
Americans do you think that it's a way
to to bridge the color divide or is it
likely that that the people who are
enjoying that music still gain no
insight into the lives of the people who
make that music first of all just a
correction of when you were saying South
Indians are discriminated against I I'm
not quite sure what kind of
discrimination you're referring to but
it's really more of sort of cultural at
you are but they would look down yeah
but not necessarily I don't know we
shouldn't be confused we're talking
about discrimination legal or a you know
civil sense sure there has always been
this sort of invisible barrier between
North India and South India that has to
do with differences of language
differences of culture and music in
different systems of music so sounds
that used to be very unfamiliar strange
alien and therefore to the lower order
that that that situation should have
changed with the with this kind of music
now coming return like Carnatic music no
I'm not talking about we're talking
about sort of popular movies yeah right
exactly out of the movies but you know
music that draws on folk folk music of
the south so what used to be very
strange and unfamiliar suddenly became
through the instrument of Bollywood a
little more accessible you know the
question that you had asked about the
gap between sort of affinity to the
music and actual affinity to the people
i'm sure patricia and and Manning will
have something to say to that but in I
don't know if I can answer that directly
because i'm not i don't really know
whether cultural attitudes have
remarkably transformed i have no basis
for for answering that question but i do
think just in a very intuitive way I
have no sort of documentation to support
my view but I do think that the kinds of
you know statements i would hear earlier
on about how this music sort of jars on
the ear I haven't heard in quite the
same way and and I as i said i'm just
saying very intuitively that this may
have something to do with the role of
bollywood in mainstream indian culture
well hip-hop right now i think the the
what-is-it eighty percent of the
audience that's right white in this
right oh the people purchase it was the
only really big white artist so
all the rest is white kids buying music
records made by black artists this is
true although this is not a new thing
that one can go back a couple centuries
and see how the creative and the musical
imagination of white America has been
structured the foundation of that has
drawn directly from or stolen from
african-american culture and music but
the difference is that in the past jazz
black art form when it became a mass of
you know a mass and mass art I was
performed by white artists when rhythm
and blues songs came along and do up on
the it was in cover records because
they've had boon records that not the
the original records that yeah better
had the big sales but today it's the
black artists and maybe that changed
with Motown but it's the black ops a
hip-hop is still relatively new and we
have Eminem as the first wave of a whole
new generation I am absolutely sure and
but I've had 20 years old but but in
terms of its mass appeal in terms of its
mass appeal and you know is I was having
a conversation with a group of other
sort of middle-class black parents all
of us having their children and in
mostly white schools and and all the
little white kids come in and they've
got baggy pants they've got on backwards
baseball caps and their ideal is hip hop
through the embodiment of Eminem and my
son you know I'm sitting here trying to
not just teach you to you know not
there's the equivalent of cricket I
suppose you know I'm said I'm it's a
very interesting play of stereotypes and
play of identities because you know I
don't want my son to be picked up by the
police you know he's and so I want him
to dress in a little polo shirt you know
that says izod on the side
his own protection it's not just about
the mind it's about how he's going to be
greeted in the world but he wants to
imitate his white classmates who are
imitating black people and inner he's
actually got you know he comes home and
he imitates and he's got the little mean
and he's doing this thing at he's do or
whatever and you know i am just appalled
I just don't know what to do but it is
this bizarre sort of cultural it's not
quite a brita T it's a sort of sloshing
back and forth of imagery that is in
which his little white classmates look
at him who really and we you know we
have no hip hop in the home at all but
they look at him and when he speaks some
of the lines the fuel eyes he's picked
up from them they think he is so
authentic they are just love it as
they've known him from kindergarten they
are and and so I think this is actually
reinforcing of certain stereotypes this
music forms of cultural functions as far
beyond the actual politics of the
original kids in the ghetto who are
expressing a real political sentiment
how it gets played out in the suburbs
are in white schools is is fascinating
to me hmm well my take on hip-hop I'm
I'm more sympathy I'm very sympathetic
to hip hop in about a year ago we had a
Russell Simmons and I had a public
dialogue here talking about the
contradictions of hip-hop culture and
music but also the strengths of it that
well just really two things just on
hip-hop itself um there's all of the
misogynistic and backward and homophobic
elements of hip-hop all embodied in
gangster rap but there are also very
progressive currents in this musical art
form from from the very beginning from
Grandmaster Flash and the Furious Five
to our nads and most def and ke RS one
that some of the young people in the
audience could immediately identify with
but the point I was trying to make with
hip-hop
is that african-americans like many
oppressed people throughout the world
through the cultural statements that
they produce their art they see their
art as way of finding voice in a society
that denies it constantly they cease art
as a tool that allows them to express
their aspirations and that here in this
country over you know repeatedly white
Americans have you know seized that tool
and turned it into their own in a way
and part of that as a function of power
and part of that is function of the
market that black artists you know even
within the hip hop tradition have been
the producers of the culture but aren't
the owners of it and that's really the
continuity questions from the audience
and please not no long speeches simple
questions
one thing I found very shocking in Cape
Town is how divided it is on the
outskirts between different races of
people from the days when they were
forcefully relocated and I just wanted
to ask you to what extent you think this
inhibits moving forward now towards
better racial unity and how it
perpetuates thoughts of value based on
race even today and what can be done
about it it is deeply offensive and it
is so horrific that it is actually
awesome in the true sense of the term
awesome um you go to Cape Town and you
go outside the city north of the city
and there's this vast ghetto called
Kylie Chia and um there's another ghetto
that is much tidier in somewhat more
middle class and I use that term very
loosely crossroads and these vast
ghettos were hundreds of thousands of
people live without running water with
pit latrines Oh close proximity
cardboard and steel tin tin roofs and
ten sides of the buildings it is so it's
hard even for us in this country to wrap
our minds around the kind of human
tragedy that exists that existed under
apartheid and that the ANC against
tremendous odds is trying to transform
all the question really points to and
the link between the question and
Midnight's Children is the legacy of
colonialism with a legacy of a par-tay
that the state always has a vested
interest in reproducing and managing
difference so that in under the British
regime there was a clear interest in the
19th century to reproduce the british
version of what they meant by
cast but in doing so they actually
constructed something that drew elements
from the historical model but was not
that that is their notion of it wasn't
was was largely fueled by the the
interest in utilities that they had as a
colonial regime to ensure the
exploitation of the masses of Indian
people in South Africa a parallel
situation occurred where you get legal
constructs of identities colored Bantu
creating a fictive category putting
people of a variety of different
ethnicities languages traditions rituals
into one size fits all and then
allocating all certain liabilities or
benefits few benefits according to the
category and so the state was
responsible for producing both these
kinds of social categories as well as
the physical kind of sites where people
live you destroy the state and yet you
can't quickly or immediately transform
the democrat the the situation on the
ground but also the situation of
division in people's heads because when
the state allocates resources constructs
a kind of public identity allocates
resources around that and then you get
rid of the state those divisions in your
head and between people don't disappear
and it takes a long time for that to be
transformed anybody want to add or
should I go to another question another
question
obviously you're very pleased with what
you are of there was over there I'm have
have you guys had an opportunity to read
the book can I can I ask you a question
from a chapter the chapter and I think
it's method and and the midnights
children when they transfer power and
the the ancestor of the original he goes
through this whole sort of I'm not sure
it's he he sets up everything for the
transfer of power at the same time that
India and Pakistan split and I wanted to
pose it to anyone and what do you think
he was actually trying to what was the
symbolism there that that's it you mean
a symbolism about transfer of power
methyl and he kept everyone had 22 he
rented out these home so he sold them
with everything in them and they had to
keep things as they were until the exact
time which there was a transfer of power
I think you've sort of even answered
your your question here because it's the
you know the continuity between the
colonial order and the post-colonial
order through the service the stability
of people homes and and material objects
and so forth and of course university
uses allegory so freely in this in the
novel to you know to make these
correspondences between the individual
and
history so I'm not sure if I'm adding
any more to what you've actually already
said in your in your comment other than
to to take it one step further to in
fact even look at sort of the the racial
diffusion of the white colonizer in the
Indian you know amongst the Indian sort
of the you know the question that
Leonard had asked earlier on about you
know mixed breed you know the idea of
that the midnights children as being
this composite as a tour of many
different races you know different
colors different different origins and
to what extent is this actually of the
offering of a new you know a secular
pluralistic India it's a way of
transforming what might be considered as
a debilitating legacy where one could
never one can never really trace one's
origin properly that every origin sort
of comes up against a stumbling block
you find that you are not as pure as you
as you thought you were but how to
transform that that that startling sense
of one's own mixed origins into the into
you know into a new set of possibility
signifying a secular pluralistic fabric
I think it might help people who haven't
read the book recently that meth walled
was Selena's father and so in nature
point and also his his antecedents were
the founders of the first colony and
Salim is the protagonist Midnight's
child who represents the new Indian my
question is is it it's it's not precise
many people i encounter who are my
friends and my students who are of
african-american descent really have
almost a knee-jerk response that salman
rushdie represents a kind of racism in
his work and I think it's really
important that that question be
addressed particularly at the beginning
of a humanities festival that is devoted
to understanding more about South Asia
and the implications for our greater
understanding of other environments that
are equally complex anyone want to
respond to that some of my students are
here I think they would probably like to
hear your response what you know Satanic
Verses has has really bothered me you
know in precisely the way that it's you
know that they're the critique of racism
doesn't quite exclude sort of the racial
characterization of other South Asians
especially you know those who you know
are relatively impoverished you know the
the for instance of depiction of the
Bangladeshi restaurant owners now the
participation in the racialization of
you know of this group you know as
opposed to other more privileged
migrants coming to England I'm not sure
if this is exactly the kind of
discussions that you've had with your
students but it's certainly a real issue
in
in the works and I think Satanic Verses
has often presented itself to my mind as
one of the most difficult novels
precisely because of it's sort of even
though you know one might say sort of a
obtrusive racism despite the critique of
racism at other levels but since rusty
has also been a critic of racism in many
ways in fact I can I even have a couple
quotes here that I'm not going to go
into but where he gets into the whole
matter of stereotyping he is a novelist
and he is a provocateur isn't he and can
we separate what we read in a novel from
the the opinions of the person who wrote
the novel I mean is he a racist because
he has people talking in racist ways I
mean I don't think it's just he has
people talking in racist ways I mean
again I I think during some of the
controversy around Satanic Verses he
spoke not as a novelist but in ways that
were deeply troubling despite the clear
equities of what was going on I I was
very troubled by what what Salman
Rushdie said the various moments and I
remember thinking that he was in many
ways in my mind very similar to Donald
woods I believe who wrote the novel cry
freedom um who you know who wrote a book
about the liberation was on the right
side of the apartheid issue but in
person would you know tell native jokes
and imitate patois and was a very
condescending British colonial product
and iiii think that that's perhaps in
the nature of human beings who write
fiction and whether we accept the
fiction is separate from the from the
beans or not but I in terms of where
this comes from I think it's pretty
straightforward where it comes from it's
not just in the novel
I think that rushing himself is a can be
a quite problematic figure in terms of
what he says directly it was going to
say that you know Manning had earlier
talked about the role of literature in
transforming people and and promoting
changed attitudes in more positive ways
but if that is the case then I do think
you know some of which these
representations are problematic because
they reinforce those very attitudes that
you know I think it would be very
difficult for a writer to take refuge by
saying I'm merely sort of having these
people who are distant from me so I
think that question of how how racism is
he's dealt with at all levels it's a
question that I think is deeply
problematic in some of the novel's the
arm my take on this is a little
different all maybe about ten percent
different I'm also troubled by
especially in this satanic verses and um
some of the imagery and some of the
language and particularly as Pat is
saying um the kinds of political
commentaries that were made as the
controversy occurred at the same time I
agree with Rosa Luxemburg that freedom
is always an only freedom she said for
the one who thinks differently so that I
believe in my politics embraces the idea
that people should be able to construct
art as they imagined it even as
contradictory and flawed as it may be
because that's where doors of
imagination open up so for me all art is
a site of contestation of challenge and
that oh you're going to find people who
produce frequently great art are deeply
is flawed in contradictory as the
societies which produce them and I'm not
sure
if I'm understanding what I would rent
some sort of special space to art for
art to do that because this is very
similar to the Thomas Jefferson question
of its it's not just in art it is a
question of can you have somebody who
writes a you know Dallas walker bush
yeah you know like people yeah what
attacked yeah the color purple happen
but Thomas Jefferson was clearly writing
in the realm of nonfiction it's not
necessarily artistic and it's
contradictory and it has actual impact
notes on Virginia so was Suzanne and so
is to go and in the end do we Celine
what do we do with those people or how
do we fashion our ideas from what they
have to say that's that is useful I
think some of many of you might be
familiar with the controversy that was
unleashed 45 years ago The New Yorker
had a special issue on India's 50th
independence and ruched he had a piece
in it where he said that no good writing
has ever come out of the Indian
vernacular languages and of course that
really just was it was a can of worms
and and it's been very hard for him to
sort of really sort of face in a face
particularly Indian reading public who
were very dismayed that such a comment
could be made and to set English up as
the superior language which alone has
produced a superior literature in India
so this is I think this again goes to
Frank's question about you know the
amino but I the question in my mind is
is this you know cut is this comment
about the the relative superiority of
literature is this a question of racism
or is this a question of a certain
literary aesthetic I mean I did this is
really i think you know we all deal with
this this question in our in our classes
that
we separate you know the the idea of
aesthetics from one's own politics or
one's own sense of race and culture and
so forth so I think that in in Rusty's
case the sort of the claim for a certain
privileged status that literature has is
even more complicated by the claim that
he makes in this article that is English
as a language which has has a privileged
status so I think that he takes it one
step further we in fact clearly losing a
part of his audience significant part of
his audience who may have had who may
have in fact supported his sort of the
integrity of art and the integrity of
the artist but feeling deeply
compromised by sort of the evaluative
criteria that came in to produce this
whole new hierarchy we've run out of
time unfortunately my great thanks to
you gary was wyeth on patricia j
williams Manning Marable and to all of
you who come here